the jurgen experience you see the lady
that got duct tape on a flight great
they duct taped their face very funny
that's wild yeah they run a frat in the
sky what do you have to do to get your
face duct tape you got to be saying some
crazy [ __ ] but they're like dude [ __ ] it
duct tape what is she doing i [ __ ] i
did it like the sopranos it's just like
takes
hot takes i i'll say it right now brian
cranston wasn't that great in breaking
bad it was like
yeah it's you got to be an obnoxious
[ __ ] to get duct taped i want to know
what they said she said
yeah anybody out there duct tape your
mouth if you hear that please reach out
to us
am i imagining that they duct tape her
mouth or did they really duct tape their
mouth yeah they got they [ __ ] tucked
it damn dude
did she sue
i don't know man i think she's in
trouble i think this woman look at this
she got fined 82 000
damn woman duct taped aboard american
airlines flight faces record 82 000
a.a oh yeah she tried to go for the door
dude
so the faa is gonna find her but does
that
is that for sure the woman assaulted and
bit a flight attendant after she
attempted to open the forward boarding
door oh [ __ ]
okay we're restrained for the safety and
the security of other customers in our
crew oh my god damn dude someone going
for the door so she bit somebody that's
why they mouth did her mouth she could
be heard screaming you you you at
passengers filling uh filing pastor as
flight attendants calmly nodded their
goodbyes
oh wow so she's screaming at them while
they're watching oh it wasn't in the air
though okay
oh it wasn't no i think they were like
they were grounded oh they were on the
way to fly which almost is like so
before they even got in the air they're
grounded and they duct taped her you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude if you're
that's the best part of they should lead
with that oh here it is she saw the
agency said she attempted to hug and
kiss another passenger tried to exit the
plane mid-flight oh she was in the
flight oh okay she was on the spot all
right never mind she tried to exit the
plane mid-flight and bit another flyer
multiple times before the queue with the
crew restrained her damn hold on
what that's different
yeah is it different lady against the
woman that says fa proposed to find the
second largest ever against a woman on a
delta flight okay so it's a different
flight so duct tape lady wasn't the lady
from las vegas to atlanta okay so this
is a second flight oh i see okay the so
this one this is only 20 21. she's
biting people we're setting new records
there's another story where there is
like uh the duct taping has it's been
happening to mulch people happen to
there's a whale that happens that he was
talking [ __ ] like what they just duct
tape people now yeah dude and then
you're in sigma chi that's how it's what
did they do to them
if that was a lady that was on the
ground that got duct taped like that so
if the other story was another person
that bit a bunch of people yeah what
what did this lady do that they didn't
just remove her from the plane they just
said no [ __ ] you're staying here
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] fly if it's on
the ground that sounds so insane just
pop the door up and get her the [ __ ] out
yeah you open the door you call the cops
they get her out like they they duct
tape they have to fly this lady that
makes no sense
is that are we right here yeah she was
saying yeah she was i think she was just
[ __ ] crazy oh my god can you use that
excuse anymore was she just [ __ ] well
there's there's levels to that okay and
don't be ableist dancing i'm sorry i'm
sorry shades of crazy duct tape
video shows women duct taped to seat
after trying to open airplane door and
apparently this is great this is i love
the post covering their ass an
apparently unhinged woman
you know she's just apparently that's
that's a cute thing
dude she's [ __ ] taped to it that is
wild as everyone's getting off would you
keep filming her like would you sit
right in front of her and try to goad
her like you would a zombie like if you
saw a zombie yeah and there was a zombie
that was chained up in someone's
basement yeah and uh i'd be like holy
[ __ ] it's a real zombie i would look
kill that [ __ ] what i'd want to see
those dead teeth i knew the zombie could
not break free you sure he can't break
free i might get close to him i'd be
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] cheat it yeah i
might be thinking
you have friends should hate brains
[ __ ] you wouldn't be here right
now
i've seen the show they're like here
they give you a louisville they're like
take a take a swing at him you get him
in the leg so if you were on this flight
yeah would you like just put the camera
in front of her not say anything i would
honestly think of i would
i would think of it yeah i would think
of something fun to say i would want a
good parting
right yeah you know what i mean seems
like you'd want to focus on her for a
few seconds according to this person
here's the scene if you it's okay it
sounds kind of crazy two-hour flight
july 6 from dallas fort worth and to
charlotte north carolina had been
delayed for at least three hours before
it finally departed at midnight but
about an hour into the trip chaos broke
out
this woman said that in a subsequent
video describing the hectic scene flight
attendants began turning on the lights
around 1 30 a.m she said and we see all
flight attendants running up and down
the aisles frantically kind of like
whispering to each other the plane's
crew began locking bathrooms grabbing
bags from overhead bins it wouldn't say
what was happening it was just kind of
like chaos and no one knows what's going
on she continued finally the pilot spoke
over the intercom asking people to stay
in their seats referencing to a bad
situation in the plane right now
according to the passenger
then we're gradually starting to hear
more and more screaming and we're like
wait a minute she noted
just as the plane was about to land a
flight attendant who sat near them
explained that a woman with an apparent
mental issue had an outburst
like had the urge to get off the plane
and she was saying i need to get off
this plane and she went up to the exits
and started banging on the doors saying
you need to let me off this plane
i guess it took five flight attendants
to subdue her and like literally take
her down so
she said of the incident which was first
reported by tmc
they pretty much took her down put her
in the seat and duct taped her damn dude
if you're
what they don't talk about is the first
guy
that noticed
because she's not telling people what
she's doing so someone's going to the
door someone's got to notice it oh my
god and you're just reading your
magazine and you're like
what the [ __ ] has anybody ever opened up
one of those doors i don't know that's a
i mean
that's going to suck everyone out right
that would just be a i wonder how easy
it is to do probably not that easy
because they always talk about the
weight of the door and you got the
pressure of being in the sky i wonder if
you can open it while the plane is
moving like i wonder if there's some
fail safes
well
i hate going with like the impossibility
and being like you can't do it but
according it's physically impossible to
open a door midfield well what if you're
like thor
what if you're a son of odin what if
you're like eddie hall like one of those
gigantic power lifters strong man dudes
cruising altitude i should say okay so
up at like 30 000 feet impossible that's
uh airplay according to this business
insider which you know best best source
for this information yeah they're
aviation airplane doors are impossible
to open at cruising altitude which is
about 36 000 feet pressurization
mimic conditions at 8 000 feet above sea
level to keep passengers imagine having
the balls
to like know that uh this person you're
traveling with is completely insane like
maybe you're dating this lady and she's
like i gotta get off this plane i've
gotta get off this plane shut up she
runs to the door but you know the
physics yeah so you just go like yeah
you're doing this
you're just doing a boyfriend an
argument thing yeah you're gonna leave
you're kicking the door in the middle of
the flight do you wanna let's dream
smart can we talk about this or are you
gonna try to open the door maybe that's
selfish to the other [ __ ] people on
the plane that you just want to fly to
the ground and everybody else has to the
guy behind you is going hey hey don't
prove nothing don't get hurt get your
girl what's going on don't prove nothing
don't what the [ __ ] are you doing oh my
god yeah that would be terrifying to
witness because again you don't know how
strong this [ __ ] you know what i'm
[ __ ] good how strong this lady
people are is they're really strong they
ripped their arms apart trying to do
something dude if she did a bump of pcp
before that plane took off and then it
was like i'm gonna start cooking at 30
000. my boxing coach got his finger
bitten off on pcp and had it replaced
with his toe
what which toe his second toe
next to the big toe
that became his index finger and he had
it curved permanently so he could throw
right hooks
wait so his hand just looks so when you
shook his hand he had he he had this
going on so it's like a toe he never
really like shook his you shook his hand
but he you got a finger in there so the
toe is this part yes the toe was this
part
so but it was permanently bent so you
could pinch things with it right but it
was permanently bad it didn't straighten
out it was like this but you could do
you could do most of the things you
could do if you had a finger there but
he got it bitten off in a street fight
while he was on pcp well he was on pc
yes
that's why i walked away oh my god okay
um after the cargo door tore off in
flight causing explosive decompression
and ejecting nine people from the plane
oh my god damn that was an 89 i remember
that damn there was a flight and the
people just got sucked out of the plane
in mid-flight
that was a hawaii fight right
going to honolulu yeah that's right
oh my god that's so scary man that
[ __ ]
that always scared me when i saw it in
movies whenever they show that and they
show the person who's been like
he's just getting like
wild wings yeah bro but also
if you're ready for it
you could do some cool poses on the way
out you could superman on the way i
think
your brain would be flooded yeah with
psychedelic chemicals because you would
absolutely 100 know you're going to die
there's no way you're going to survive
and you would probably get a golden
geometric pattern that opens up and
takes you straight to the afterlife yeah
you just come and [ __ ] at the same time
your body's like let it all happen
and you just pass through and you pop on
the other side like on impact
dude and in reality it just looks like a
jelly sandwich hit the ground whoever's
near you they never talk about those
people that watch people land yeah
you're just like oh it's coming through
the air it's not good are you
splattering